I've been trying to prepare myself for
this first segment because this is some
of the funniest stuff that I have ever
seen Donald Trump went to India to hang
out with Indian Prime Minister Narendra
Modi who actually shares some policy
ideas with Trump Trump doesn't want to
fund dealing with climate change Modi
cut the budget for dealing with the
environment by 50% Modi wants to
privatize the economy on and sort of
neoliberal framework the same way that
Donald Trump does many similarities
between the two leaders
so Trump goes to India and Modi speaks
and then Trump speaks before a massive
crowd embarrasses himself by
mispronouncing so much stuff and there's
video of the crowd
literally fleeing the stadium like the
the exits are packed it's as if the
Patriots are up 40 in the fourth quarter
and the place is clearing out to avoid
traffic and the visual it's like a
horror movie it's like a disaster movie
where everyone is just running away from
Donald Trump's speech
it's so embarrassing in every way and
let's go through it it started really
oddly with Trump walking out into the
stadium to the tune of the Village
People song macho man it's already weird
I'm not gonna play that segment because
I don't want to have copyright issues
today we had plenty yesterday which I'll
tell you about later and check this out
listen now this is very risky stuff to
put on a teleprompter in front of Donald
Trump
the name swami vivekananda that's risky
and Trump of course refers to him as
Cameron dude and it's just as good as it
sounds as the great religious teacher
Swamy VV come on none what's a
that's a doozy I mean like why even put
that up on a prompter for Trump right
it's just relentlessly a
self-destructive then Trump mangles the
names of two Indian cricket stars
Tendulkar and Kohli and this is just so
entertaining where your people cheer on
some of the world's greatest cricket
players from Suchi kendo he also
mispronounced Vedas ancient Hindu
religious texts as Vestas wishes
something else altogether and then of
course the place by the time Trump was
done speaking was half empty or more
because thousands tens of thousands of
people were running for the exits while
Donald Trump was speaking Trump of
course trying to sell it as you know I
had a crowd of a hundred thousand and
it's true at the outset it was very very
full but the report from the BBC is that
as the speech went on and Trump was
making a fool out of himself people
started to get up and leave and you can
see in the video a crowd formed at the
exits people could not exit quickly
enough and as you can see if you're
watching the stadium ends up half-empty
while Donald Trump is is talking can you
imagine the BBC reporting quote crowds
began leaving midway through the US
president speech that let's now check
out the video with the audio and you
will see that as Donald Trump is
speaking the exits are crammed it's
almost like a bomb went off and
everybody's trying it's like the place
is on fire and people are trying to get
out of a crowded theater people barely
able to squeeze out as Donald Trump is
speaking take a look richy's were young
at all take pride in the glory
unite for an even brighter future and
let our two nations always stand
together as powerful defenders of peace
and liberty and the hope of a better
world it's amazing just one
laughingstock after another it is truly
truly amazing stuff and overall a very
embarrassing trip for the United States
Donald Trump being in India as is often
the case I mean it's often the case that
when Donald Trump travels abroad it's
it's very embarrassing for the United
States and this is one of the things
that you know it's going to take some
time once Trump is gone there will be
relationships that have to be rebuilt
the the sort of I don't I don't even
necessarily want to call it prestige but
the knowledge on the behalf of our our
allies and counterparts geopolitical
counterparts they're not all allies
their knowledge that they are dealing
with a real diplomat someone that can be
trusted someone who understands things
that's going to take some time to
rebuild a lot of those relationships and
the next thing I want to talk about is
the wacky press conference that Donald
Trump gave I guess it would be sort of
this morning india time during this trip
let's talk about that next if you watch
the David Pakman show you should check
out a YouTube channel we're partnering
with called up flip click the link right
underneath this video it'll take you to
their channel while you're there make
sure to subscribe and click that bell
for notifications up flip is the channel
perfect for anyone like me who's
fascinated with small businesses and
entrepreneurs and what makes them tick
and every Wednesday up flip uploads a
new video where they interview an
entrepreneur they give you an inside
look at how the business works what
makes the business successful what a day
in their shoes is really like if you
enjoy shows like Shark Tank I think
you'll really like this channel and
again the channel is called up flip
they're friends of the David Pakman show
I'd love it if people in my audience
subscribe to their channel click the
bell so that you get updates about their
videos and I've put a link right below
that will take you directly to their
YouTube channel check it out